thrilled to have on the phone line a
friend it's been a while since we talked
to this 14-year veteran the national
football league the bengals and the
ravens are playing a game for first
place in the nfc north winner
wins the who takes the game takes first
place in the afc north through seven
weeks of the season uh long time bengal
and of course cardinal and a cup of
coffee with the raiders our friend from
usc football none other than carson
palmer how you doing carson
good job thanks for having me on thanks
for coming on how's life how's
everything what are you up to these days
good yeah we are
healthy happy we're strong uh we just
finished our huge huge season for the
wood river middle school seventh grade
boys football team okay uh just finished
that up on wednesday night how'd we do
um we did we did
we did average um
we ended up going three and four
but it was a lot of a lot of first year
players so first time putting the helmet
on strapping on pads but uh we got a lot
of work to do before the eighth grade
season starts who do you conjure you
can't you can't conjure aryans right
with children correct there's about a
lot of earmuffs if you conjure yours no
no i i i definitely go back into uh i
was fortunate enough to play for some
some great ones obviously bruce one of
them pete and there's half of his
dialogue
he was in there too there's a lot of
there's a lot of pete in me okay uh as a
coach and and uh the good clean part of
bruce
uh his his vocabulary so it's been fun
a lot of gum chomping you're like pete
you're you're up and down up and down
the sideline chomping gum carson no
longer no gum no mountain dew um i i
don't need the i don't need the the
stimulants i just i get hyped i get
pumped
i'm a good cup of coffee in the morning
and i'm ready to roll oh yes coach
carson palmer how about that joining me
here on the rich eisen show um so what
do what do we make of the bengals so far
here like this is seems like it's coming
together
in cincinnati carson right man that
offense is explosive i mean
um jamar chase there was a lot of
concerns about about his preseason but
he has just exploded on the scene i mean
joe mixon joe burrow i mean they're
really really explosive t higgins on the
outside
um
it's so fun to watch joe i mean he is so
calm and so poised for for being such a
young player um you know then that
division is is open if they can get past
baltimore we'll see what happens but
just such a fun offense to watch and
then they're stingy on defense and and
tough and aggressive so it's been a fun
season to watch what was the biggest you
know regular season game you played with
the bengals when you were trying to earn
the stripes figuratively literally for
you when it was actually like
what's i guess in front of burrow right
now first overall selected quarterback
so many hopes go into
you and when was that regular season
game for you do you remember that back
in your day carson yeah i mean
being in the afc north was with you know
two of the premier organizations in
pittsburgh and baltimore they're just
always good you know when you go into
baltimore it's going to be a hostile
environment you know they're going to be
really good on defense and just salty
and big and fast and aggressive you know
they're going to run the ball and then
you go to pittsburgh and just the
tradition and history of that
that organization you know as a bengals
player you always want to beat the
steelers
but those two those two games
always stood out in my mind my biggest
kind of welcome nfl moment was the first
time going to baltimore
and winning on the road when they were
number one or two in total defense that
season
yeah because this is it right i mean
like this would be
especially after last year that got
blown up because of his blown-up knee
and i know that they've won four of
their first six but this would be the
one
to basically say yeah we are for real
and not just for the future like down
the line like we have something here
called higher register where you go your
voice goes to the higher register to
make you believe it like you know hey
the bengals look out for them like that
sort of thing is what you say but this
would be like the real deal like okay
now the future's now present is now like
that's what's on the line here on sunday
it's a statement game no doubt about it
i mean you go into baltimore and win in
baltimore and and you know now looking
at that that division it's full of young
really talented quarterbacks with baker
and and lamar and obviously joe um but
this this is the game if if they're if
they're for real and they're going to
win that division this is the game you
go in and they can do it too i mean
they're
baltimore's really really good on
defense and uh you know you can imagine
humphrey probably be trying to man up
one-on-one against jamar case or jamar
chase um so so the match-ups in this
game are really good um but i you know
if if
you know i was a betting guy i'd say i'd
say the bengals have a shot to go in
there and win carson palmer here on the
rich eisen show i remember you were here
on this program
a couple of springs ago and just after
brady had signed with the bucks and
you're like this is going to be a great
marriage this is going to be a great
match and last year it kind of looked
like last year would have been the time
to go get
the bucks and try and knock them off
because they were still
trying to
figure each other out or what one likes
and what one doesn't like and they still
won a super bowl anyway in that
transition period this now seems like
they're on cruise control like that
they're he brady's comfortable and
aryans doesn't
you know an aryan sits back there and
knows that he and left witch are all
locked in and the three of them together
are locked in it looks like this is
the high level functioning or or is
there another gear that we're not
talking about
carson what do you think well just just
hearing you you know explain the
dynamics of that thing the first thing i
thought of was man it's also a dangerous
recipe like that that mindset let's just
get to the playoffs let's just get
healthy to the player you know that
that kind of mindset um is your probably
biggest enemy because they are that good
i mean they are that much better than
than most the teams in the league
getting off the bus for the most part
they're a more talented bus
um
but that kind of mindset can catch up to
you and and you can get beat by a team
that probably should never you know has
no chance
has no reason to really beat you but
those are the games that get you in
trouble but i mean they're they are so
uh they're such a well-oiled machine
right now in the the first six or seven
eight weeks of last season you could
tell there were some issues just with
timing and rhythm of the passing game
but i mean they're firing on all
cylinders right now and with with top
bowls on defense and and that group that
he has rushing the passenger and
covering on the back end
um it's just it's a really really well
constructed and built team and um you
know i just hope that they don't that
you know if you have anybody that can
keep you out of that mindset it's tom
brady and bruce you know not letting you
get complacent not letting you look past
the next opponent i guess cruise control
does have a connotation that's negative
i'm just saying that it looks like
whatever feeling out period is
definitely over i mean it's over it's
long gone like brady's comfortable he is
ready every single game with a with a
mindset of knowing where he wants to go
and it just seemed like last year when
they went seven and five it looked like
that they were still
trying to figure each other out and
that's done that's over and and i'm i'm
just wondering if this is the the level
of offense that aryans was looking for
last year and brady was as well or they
can actually get better i mean is that
possible in any way
it's absolutely possible you know
they
were really trying to figure out bruce's
and and byron's offense in the first
five six seven eight weeks last year
you can see that there there's been a
mesh of of what brady really loves what
he's really comfortable with
a lot of his strengths and maybe some of
that some of the josh mcdaniels and bill
o'brien stuff he was running in in new
england forever um so you can see i mean
you're right i mean they just
there's no miscommunications there were
so many times last year mike evans would
break in and the ball would the ball
would be thrown out or vice versa and
you're just not seeing that anymore so
um
there's a lot of football to be played
you know as as as the season goes on if
they can stay healthy
um the sky is the limit i mean they're
top three four in every category on
offense there's no reason they can't
finish the season number one in most
those categories carson palmer here on
the rich eisen show what's your best
guess or educated guess
on aaron rodgers and thinking that maybe
this is the place to stay anyway you
know i know you guys kind of share an
agent and i know that you know uh
veteran quarterbacking and
and places that you definitely want to
play in or feel that you want to play in
certain spots i'm just wondering what
your
your sixth sense tells you about this
great start for green bay packers fans
are hoping that this is just everything
that just happened this past year goes
away
what do you think of of that
car yeah i think i think if they if they
win the super bowl there's no way he can
leave i mean if if they if they win the
super bowl he can't say that
you know the organization's not willing
to do what it takes to get it done um
but if he doesn't if it just depends on
what other spot is open and and what
other team
is ready to take that on
um but i mean it they're they're in it i
you know you watch them play and they've
got a little bit of everything at the
end of the day they've got aaron rodgers
who's probably the most talented and
gifted
uh player in the league and when you
have that you've always got a shot so
um
if they win a super bowl he's got a he's
you know i can't imagine him leaving and
playing anywhere else
but if they don't or they have an early
exit i mean i have no idea where that is
but i i could easily see him departing
so right now kind of kumbaya five game
win streak we'll see how it goes it
really does depend on how
what the end game scenario is
is what you're saying
i think so i i think so i mean if
there's no reason to leave if they can
win the super bowl
and and
the team has you know and you you as a
quarterback have proven that that you're
the best in the league you can't leave
that situation hey man i mean they they
snapped up uh jalen smith whitney
merciless they just signed this week
right they they got randall cobb
because aaron's like go get him
it does seem like
the trust and respect that he kept on
talking about aaron that this has
been reciprocated i don't know i'm
sitting on outside looking in i also
don't have the brain of a quarterback so
that's why i'm asking you you know and
they resigned uh aaron jones to a big
deal to keep him in the backfield and
give him that option that that i mean
and and just watching aaron this thus
far through the season aaron jones that
is i mean he he is such a dynamic player
and so explosive and so great paired
with aaron so
um yeah i mean they're they're showing
that they're willing to do you know go
after it and hopefully put all the
jordan love and and you know those
things the lack of the first round picks
from the offensive side of the ball or
any
um highly drafted receivers in the past
i mean all those things that have come
up um
a super bowl cures all those the super
bowl overshadows all of those those
things that come up throughout the
season throughout a player's career now
let's finish up by talking about another
one of your former teams the only
remaining undefeated team in the nfl and
that's the arizona cardinals what do you
think of when you see somebody like kyla
murray play quarterback in the same
uniform as as you did
well what goes through your mind seeing
somebody like lamar too you know what i
mean it just it's it's it's must be wild
for you it's absolutely wild i mean
he he's the most exciting player in my
opinion to watch play right now he's one
of the the handful of guys when when you
talk about
um i gotta go see him play you gotta go
see him play in person
it's just so different it's so quick
it's so explosive
and he's got so much touch on the
football
um and and it's it's really effortless
coming off his hand just his natural
quick release that natural whip he has
it's almost like a shortstop and i know
he's got a baseball playing background
but um it's just so fun to watch and um
they're speaking about well-built and
well-constructed teams i mean they've
got playmakers on the back end and
buddha baker on their defense they've
got you know
aggressiveness and size and relentless
with jj watt up front and then chandler
jones rushing the passengers one of the
best pass rushers over the last decade
or so in the nfl
um and offensively they just have a ton
of weapons i mean it all obviously all
starts with with uh hopkins but
it's just a really really well-built
team
but right now watching tyler play i mean
it is it is the game is just happening
so slow for him and he is so much
quicker and more explosive than every
player on the field um it's been a blast
a while i agree with you about the
well-built team carson because again
eight let's just think about it aj green
jj watt correct now zach ertz
right i mean those are just three guys
right there who are so crucial to this
team's success and none of them are in
that so-called have to do it you're the
man number one on the depth chart roll
james connor
is another one right that they're all
meshing together and all of them are in
somewhat you would say complementary
roles as opposed to you have to be the
man roles and i think they're
loving that i think they're loving that
like let kyler tyler's the man right and
deandre can be the man he wants the ball
90 times a game because he deserves it
but i guess like the way that it's all
being supplemented ertz zack ertz right
like this is
they're all in complementary roles of
guys who have been there and done that
before and i think they're they're
thriving
in that yeah
and kyler is no vet i mean kyler's young
he only really played one year college
football then started as a rookie and
you know it's not like he's been in the
league for a decade so he's got like all
the guys you mentioned i mean the
experience of jj watt and and guys like
aj green and having those
those guys in a locker to keep things
cool because there's going to be a bump
in the road you know as as they go on
and the season progresses there's more
and more pressure
can they go undefeated you know and and
just having that veteran leadership in
that locker room hey guys one week at a
time and keeping that focus and keeping
that mindset
when you do have some young explosive
players on offense and defense it's
really nice to have those veteran you
know those leaders those kind of voices
in the locker room keeping everybody
cool under all the pressure of can we go
7-0 can we go eight can we go nine and
um it's just a really well-constructed
team it reminds me of my time in arizona
and steve kind brought in um you know
carlos dansby who who had been to
arizona and cleveland and um bringing
that veteran in that locker room um
you know lorenzo alexander another great
special teams um pro bowler that ended
up having a great defensive career in
buffalo but bringing in those kind of
guys is always huge and it's so nice
being a young quarterback like tyler is
and having those opinions around you in
the locker room last one for you carson
do you think tua could be a big time
quarterback in this league there's so
much talk now about the dolphins are
going to try to trade for deshaun again
and then it just seems inevitable that
that's the way this is going to wind up
do you think tua can be a guy in the nfl
or is he just never seen it i mean i we
haven't seen it yet he hasn't proved it
um i mean the big thing coming out of
of alabama was was injuries and issues
staying healthy and
the high ankle sprain just some of the
things that have come up um
you know he hasn't proven that that side
the durability side
um but you know there's just not enough
not enough film not enough experience
yet that you can make a decision on a
guy like him with that natural athletic
ability that natural talent
that natural style to be able to play at
his best and at the biggest moments like
he did in college
um you know he hadn't put that on film
in the nfl yet so until he does that
and can stay healthy
he's got a lot of proven to do for sure
carson thanks again appreciate it go
back to being a dad sounds like i took
you away from uh from dad duty of some
sort uh throughout this conversation
always i appreciate it thanks for having
me right back at you that's carson
palmer at carsonpalmer3 on instagram
right here on the rich eisen show the
great carson palmer
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here